this is Dom he's a friendly Little Robot
that's super good at only one thing
setting up a butt ton of dominoes really
really fast it's taken five years to get
to this Mark rober's videos are wacky
fun and jam-packed with science they're
also wildly popular 22 million YouTube
subscribers tune in to watch them and
this year he's nominated for six streamy
Awards including creator of the year now
he's working with Jimmy Kimmel on
revengeineers a new show for the
Discovery Channel Jamie wax spent some
time with Robert his secret lab in
California Jamie you gotta explain some
stuff I will explain it all Michelle
good morning it's called crunchlabs a
massive Willy Wonka style Factory filled
with experiments and Creations Robert's
videos and the activity kit see now
offers are inspiring young people to
embrace science in the classroom and as
a career
let's join him and watch Mr Wizard
oh hi
[Music]
oh hi Rita come on in these are the
Science Guy
[Music]
multiple Generations have gained an
interest
in science and technology from
entertaining experts so I understand
we're ending with a bang yes
performing fun experiments and so now in
our case instead of pumping we fill this
tank up with high pressure nitrogen gas
for today's audience
Mark Rober has taken that concept over
the top I think you are the new
incarnation of something that has been
going on a long time you teach facts in
a very fun way yeah I like to hide the
vegetables right like get kids stoked
about science and education and
Engineering without realizing that's
what's happening
I bring you in with you know world's
largest jello pool and it's a banger
thumbnail and it's like what a 15 ton
jello pool
before you know it you're learning about
chemistry and the scientific method and
how he came to this
and it's not just kids who become
obsessed with his work the biggest
compliment I can get is when like a
family says like the parents are like I
love your videos my kids also love your
videos right so could it be like this
Pixar thing where it's like it kind of
works on on many different levels Rover
worked at Nasa for 10 years then Apple
for five
[Applause]
but when it got to 10 million followers
he followed his heart and his
opportunities and changed direction to
be fair I was making more money off
YouTube than I was at Apple for a few
years but then I was like you know what
I just need to do this thing full time
so basically white shirt cut a hole in
the front
cut a hole in the back I had like a
video about a decade ago a Halloween
costume or an iPad in front an iPad and
back we do a FaceTime video chat it
looks like you have a hole in your body
and I uploaded it to YouTube and the
next day it had like a million and a
half views it's like on the front page
of these websites and I was like well
this is a cool feeling because I have
more ideas his chance of being rewarded
for Creative Innovation began while
growing up as a quiet and introverted
child who didn't speak until he was four
years old in third grade we got the
standardized test back and you know I
did pretty well on them and my mom saw
the scores and she was like oh I'm so
sorry but there's a mistake here this is
definitely not my son right they'd
always used to be like plug in mark this
is like what they'd say because I I
lacked a certain amount of common sense
but he didn't lack creative sense it was
when he was a kid that he came up with
his first hack I was like five years six
years old and my mom asked to help with
dinner and so so you know she had me
cutting onions so I went upstairs and
got some swim goggles and now this is
like understood as a life hack but I was
like a five-year-old and there was no
BuzzFeed back then to get these hacks on
right that made such an impact on her
and I remember her laughing and just
thinking it was super clever his mother
passed away from ALS just six months
before he posted his first video it's
this really interesting thing where it's
like you don't know the full measure of
your impact even while you're here you
know what I mean like she was the
biggest influence on My Life by a
comfortable margin welcome
the secret entrance the idea is you come
in here and you don't know that there's
a super high-tech lab behind this
bookshelf so here we come where Theory
becomes practice this is a spot yeah
this is kind of the Arena so we we build
it in the other room and then we can
bring it in here to test it we visited
him at crunch Labs his testing space
slash Studio outside San Francisco and
then
I was able to see and even try out a few
of his most famous Creations here we go
yes that was amazing I have to ask you
how much danger are you actually in in
these experiments I really do try and
bring the viewer along for the ride and
we don't know what will happen when we
go out and do these things so here is
our first test shot just I want to be
careful and not make kids think it's
okay to take risks
many of his proudest accomplishments
have taken place outside the lab
like declaring war on the thieving
squirrels in his backyard and so I was
like well I'm a NASA engineer I can
protect my bird seed against these
squirrels so it became Like a Man versus
squirrel thing an obstacle course and
declaring war on thieving scam call
centers they do about 20 million dollars
a year and we basically used engineering
to come up with like smoke bombs you
know obviously glitter bombs we had this
one time delay lunch box and like 100
cockroaches came out of course we hacked
their CCTV so we could watch the whole
thing unfold real time
the point is I made a story and I
brought you along for the ride so that
people would share this video and here
it is my goal with crunch Labs is to
help you think like an engineer his
latest passion is called the crunchlabs
build box a challenging educational toy
that's delivered monthly so in this one
we learn all about flywheels and sort of
the Quan effect and how frisbees fly
yeah
wow look at this so it's one thing to
passively watch a video but to get there
and to be building like alongside me as
I show you how to put it together and
then teach you how it works and so I
love this idea of just making it so
accessible that you know hopefully
anyone can put themselves in my shoes
and think you know this is a cool thing
I could do this I could see myself as
that as an engineer this you might
recognize yes this is where it all
started and all of this has led Mark
Rober to his biggest and most rewarding
engineering project yet his remarkable
life and using the power of pneumatics
you just step off oh my gosh could you
have imagined this life for you no and
it's so ridiculous but do I know where
I'll be 10 years from now absolutely not
but what I can promise you is I'm gonna
keep trying my hardest on every single
Rock I'm on and then just see where the
path leads
wow he is really something and that
crunchlabs build box is a great gift if
you have a creative curious kid I want
to see revenge and ears now it's great
you know this is what he does if anyone
out there has been a victim of Porsche
Pirates has been talked about a lot I
love this I love this he created these
glitter bombs for porch Pirates so just
Google that that's fun enough all right
thanks Jimmy good stuff